I think there's a couple of things that
are that typically happened when a
company gets sold and why a company gets
sold you know one reason is that the
stock is in the toilet and that the CEO
sees the handwriting on the wall and
says I get to get out of this it's not
going to get any better if we can get a
premium for our shares we should take it
and we should run like the wind that
that's that's one scenario you have
other centers where companies owned by a
family for example you have a situation
like the sale of Dow Jones frankly where
you have a family whose divided who some
people need money want money some others
don't and depending on who wins perhaps
they decide to sell the company you have
generational change you have situations
where a company or a company may have a
CEO a great leader of a CEO who's going
to retire and then the board has to save
themselves how we going to continue
running this company well maybe the
better option is to sell the company to
a buyer and then of course you have
hostile deals where a company approaches
you on a hostile basis and depending on
how the market reacts you may not have a
choice
you